[Music]
in
any competition you expect greatness to
seal the deal
but sometimes you get the exact opposite
of that
performing at the highest level isn't
easy but it's what fans expect
from the best talent in the world that's
why when a player or team
fails to do so it can be hard to forget
here are the top 10
chokes in esports every team would love
to start the split by extending their
undefeated run
but with success like that fans expected
positive results in the playoffs
at the beginning of 2020 the lcs saw
cloud9 get off to a
roaring 12-0 start in the spring split
which they ended up winning but they
will not stop it
cloud9 waited six years and they will
hoist the trophy again
for all five players the first time in
their careers
the nexus falls licorice deals the
killing blow
and cloud9 when the 2020 lcs spring
split
but despite a strong 9-0 start to the
summer split
one of the best years in cloud 9's
history ended in
3-1 losses to flyquest and tsm
in the playoffs with blabber down it is
a 2v4
cloud9 started this season looking so
damn good but tsm have risen to the
occasion
they have taken down the nexus tourists
they will take down
the remaining players on the cloud 9
roster for the first time in
seven years c9 will not be attending
worlds
a year full of promise destroyed in a
single series
now that is a big choke
and next entry can't be boiled down to a
single
choke but instead covers an entire era
where a team that seemed legitimately
terrifying
just couldn't help but choke when it
mattered and it all comes down to
sipnicks here
1v4 he's got 15 seconds and k denies it
denvy
team solomid cs roster which would later
become known as australis
seemed to have a bright future ahead of
them but they had
one problem they could never make it to
the grand finals of a major tournament
more pressure than they've ever had on
them here freiburg spraying through the
smoke is gonna take down one
dupree goes down and csm they drop out
nip they're gonna be in the semifinals
once again but the team's inability to
clinch
made their eventual coming out party at
the 2017 e-league major
all the more satisfying he goes down
with the max 70 can't make it happen
finally pasha coming in with a refract
but he's down the bomb has been picked
up by dupreeh they get the spray neal
takes one and how's it there
and astral as they win the first major
championship
16-14 against flutter throw
unbelievable
love it or hate it overwatch is a game
where every alt
is important especially when we're
talking about a team fight
nanny as he's moving over he just sees a
flash
a hint out of the corner of his eye his
peripheral vision
then he's got the eyes of a hunter and
sees michelle over there
in the quarterfinals of overwatch league
stage one playoffs the new york
excelsiors nanae
seemingly tried to use his grav to catch
michelle sombra
out of position not there for fled up
they can still make this work but it's
going to be in overtime
as they work their way forward what was
that
away it doesn't do jack with the team
fight lost
the seoul dynasty locked up the series
even the casters called it while it was
and then they choked
gonna be ticking down and they've
actually done it
chokes at the final hour throws the grab
off to the side
and dynasty say thank you very much
we're going to the semi
dota 2 is an unforgiving game and
players will do
whatever it takes in game to get even
the smallest of advantages
the job as a captain of dota is just to
try and win by any means necessary it
was for that reason
that kyle swindle melons friedman
dropped his yule scepter of divinity on
the ground
a risky move especially during game
three of complexity's lower bracket
match against virtus pro at
ti5 so there's a lot of math involved
here but basically
you're dropping that item and lowering
your stats temporarily to gain a
slight benefit from an on-use item in
this case
a soul ring but when he dropped the item
it didn't go to plan he was ganked and
the yules
was lost at the same time voters pro now
like they've still been farming the
entire time echo slam swindle
real trouble fng they bring down the
storm spurt
who are you trying to call since i think
swindle knows just lost his
i think he dropped it to get more out of
his bottle in the bottom lane oh
and it got destroyed by the shaker when
he ganked him with the echo so that's a
2 800 gold loss now we don't know for
sure the complexity would have won the
game if this
yours hadn't been destroyed but losing
it sure made it a lot harder to win
and in a must win game three we have to
call this one like it is
a big choke
if you're a team liquid cs go fan my
condolences
because you've seen enough choking to
last a lifetime
but maybe the worst example from their
storied history was that
mlg columbus 2016 where they faced off
against luminosity gaming in the major
semi-final
up 15-9 on mirage just a
single round away from victory liquid
collapsed and lost 15 19 in overtime
and the crowd just sounded stunned
versus three
this is for everything this is for the
map right now nico making its way
around the smoke this family will spot
taco but that's it luminosity with a
comeback from 1510
an amazing play from cole with the awp
all the way back into overtime into a
victory
10 rounds in a row for illuminati then
on map 2 up 15 to 6 on cash
it happened again as they fell 16-19 in
overtime
friend needs a one versus four retake
with an awp and there it is cold he's
going to take his head off and
luminosity
will find themselves in the grand finals
against navi
[Applause]
it is perhaps one of the most notorious
chokes in the history of the game
and a harsh reminder that being a liquid
csgo fan
is often not for the faint of heart
everyone has a bad day now and then but
sometimes your bad day has
extreme consequences should be on the
hands of mushy and back goes the hands
of windrunner
yeah no what they denied it
they failed oh oh we see a lot of rares
being in and out
for witnessing at ti3 with the series
tied one-on-one
kyxy of orange esports made history
when he accidentally denied his own
team's aegis
after killing rocha you don't really
kill roxanne for the experience and gold
you kill it for that ages
it must be like like attack moving there
or something like that it's definitely
an accident it is most definitely an
accident
this isn't the ultimate dis up against
na'vi saying we don't need no eggs
that's an accident orange was so far
ahead of their opponents
navi that even without it it seemed like
a comeback was
pretty unlikely but whether it was the
raw tilt from losing the aegis or the
lack of the item's
actual effect orange somehow found a way
to lose this in position the game with a
double kill
mushy almost dead is dead mushy down
sk will fly back and gj navi
they come back from what looked like
oblivion
to get into their third international
grand
final losing a commanding lead when you
should be able to close out the game is
a
textbook choke and doing it in the grand
finals of a manger is something the evil
geniuses are
very familiar with in the grand finals
of the sixth invitational 2018
the canadian-led evil geniuses roster
looked like he was ready to close it out
against penta sport
neck rocks inching up so close one goes
down pengu doesn't look sees the mute
neck rocks in canadian it's 5-2
for eg and neck rock still uncontested
eg one nap away from the championship
but penta never gave up and after
winning cafe with thrilling finishes on
both bank and
coastline they were able to complete the
reverse sweep
one will cover the doorway as they start
to defuse pengu goes for one on the
young can he go the second
they're often known as the best team in
the world never having that distinction
until today penta are your world
champions the second invitational
but as we pointed out in our video about
it this
actually happened to eg again at the pro
league season 9 finals
a single round from winning their match
against
empire canadian decided to peak oregon's
white stairs
and the collapse began anew as empire
rolled back into eg and into pro
league's history
in another 1v2 no less nvk will watch as
geo goes for the plant the sound q will
give damn the information oh he takes
one down
empire will rise as you crown a new
champion
here in milan an addition of dan to this
team
proves to be what's needed and this
miracle come back from evil geniuses
will be all but a dream
empire are your season nine champions
when your game is at evo you expect a
hype grand
finals but smash ultimate's 2019
tournament look like it might actually
just be a clean 3-0
tweet came in from winner's side and was
up 2-0
over mk leo needing only one more win
with his pokemon trainer to take home
first place
tweek is so far ahead of leo we saw leo
continually
land in the tweak again and again he
keeps eating these fourth smashers he's
leading
he's eating these aerials tweek is on
his way to winning evo 2019
but even battered leo's joker was
one step ahead of the competition as he
rallied and
turned the tide tweak had great chances
to close out the first set
including being up two stalks in game
four but leo
reset the bracket and swept tweek in the
second
series to steal the championship waiting
for the third jab
so smart he's gonna try to go low can he
spike it he mistimes it he grabs the
left
and with that mk lego defeats tweek to
be your 2019
evo champion you can dread it you get
rough from it
but in the end mk leo will arrive
in grand finals our runner-up entry
goes to one of the hardest to watch
moments in street fighter history
punk's lost to taquito at evo 2017.
punk was nas great hope at evo 2017
and heading into the grand finals he
looked like a lock
here we'll see what happens sweep
punk staying alive and you can see how
happy it was i've never seen him so
emotional so invested in a match
right well he knows that this is it this
is the biggest match of his life
entering the grand finals from the
winner's side punk just had to take a
set to put taquito away
but when the murder face reset the
bracket no one was sure how punk would
react
you can see he's unsettled punk is not
ready for this there's so much pressure
on
take some time take some time do not
jump back into this match
he did the thumbs up this is what
happens it's slipping from him he can
see
evolution it's just right out of his
reach
taquito came out furiously in the second
set and pressured punk until he broke
with a 3-0 sweep he's got the trigger if
he finds a hit he'll kill
he jumped onto it he baited the throw
that's it that's it tokido is the
evolution
2017 champion coming all the way from
losers bracket
he's done it now punk is still young so
he has plenty of time to bring
n a there dude it just didn't happen
this time
at number one is a choke that has
already ended up in more than a few of
our videos
so what's one more right at eleague
major boston in 2018
the hometown crowd was treated to
history as
north america's cloud9 took home their
region's first
cs go major but across from them was a
phase clan super team that was facing
huge expectations that they simply
failed to meet
fittingly faze's major run would end
with guardian
outnumbered and alone on the bomb site
patiently as cloud9 sets the push up oh
oh this happens they made it work clown
nine are your elite major champions
even if guardian one day earns his major
win this one won't be fading into
history
anytime soon so those were our top 10
jokes
in esports have you guys ever choked in
the game before
i've uh i've never choked before but
just before you guys go
make sure you hit that subscribe button
we are on the road to two
million subs and you can help us get
there thanks for watching guys
and i'll see you all in the next one
thanks for watching
if you want more content like this hit
the sub button and ring that
notification bell
for unique bite size videos you won't
find anywhere else
hit up our instagram twitter and
facebook pages